look at my [ __ ] hair it's crazy it's
crazy lucky I have a woman because if I
didn't [ __ ] would be hard to come by
hey what's going on you two are you guys
doing you look good you look fantastic
sexy as hell
nuts that galled type regina all shook
up about you thought you killed
I don't even write this [ __ ] out I kind
of just go on and blab see what comes
out which is why I lost a lot of my
friends please subscribe now recently a
subscriber asked now before we get into
this though I'm not gonna actually read
it verbatim I'm just going to paraphrase
it and just okay now I've been with my
girlfriend now for a couple of years but
recently a lot of my friends have been
saying that the type of friendships that
I have outside of with my girlfriend are
a little bit inappropriate and I should
be more conscious of her feeling my
girlfriend has a said anything our
relationship is fine but everybody else
is making me feel uncomfortable and
making me feel like I'm doing something
wrong what should I do
mother forgot a way for the subject oh
yes you know it's a very interesting
thing to me like especially when it
comes to your relationship like you said
your girlfriend is completely okay with
it so it begs to wonder why the [ __ ] is
it with everything's fine in our world
somebody else got to have a side comment
and say some [ __ ] about what the [ __ ]
I'm doing for those people out there
they got a know their [ __ ] way into
your relationship I got a couple of
things for them number one [ __ ] ain't
none of your business
number two rich ain't none of your
business number three nobody [ __ ]
loves you yeah [ __ ] them it is the most
oddest thing to me when other people
bring their insecurities about what's
[ __ ] up in their life and try to
project it on to you and trust me for me
I know exactly where you're coming from
because I read it in all the comments oh
my god David is talking to Julie Shawn
it's his girlfriend okay with this oh my
god are Tina and David going out behind
Muriel's back look here you dumb [ __ ]
your [ __ ] dick cheese smelling mother
I love any idea how hard it was for me
to get Muriel to go out with me do you
think that I have enough magic up my
sleeve to get three attractive women to
talk to me mother [ __ ] you know what you
making me feel good about my girl Muriel
was not an easy task
I had a briber
with cheese like like a ruler job over
the world well baby you not I read you
the route of my life because I'm a cage
and I'm the hay that you pee on because
we try to make a comfortable bed this is
not making sense
listen here you [ __ ] nosy [ __ ]
license but I understand that in your
past relationships you got cheated on
because you were okay
with your boyfriend or your girlfriend
talking to somebody else and that little
[ __ ] cheating [ __ ] decided to go
ahead and step out on you when you gave
them your trust but guess what that was
your relationship not mine not his
we cool when you see a healthy
relationship don't try to sabotage it
learn from it and say hmm how can I get
what they have [ __ ] negative ass
[ __ ] you have any idea how weird
it is I'm calling you negative
[ __ ]
hmm hmm not a person that you're not you
Peter not Peter don't attack me because
person is in picture like the person is
in picture London if your life is so
miserable you go fix your [ __ ] and let
me live my completely happy just as an
example I have this comment on YouTube
from this one chick or [ __ ] I say this
because you said a bitch-ass comment
[ __ ] oh my god I wouldn't be
okay if my man was talking to another
girl like that I'm trying to stir up
drama in my life my life is right and
that's what I'm talking about see you
had this past relationship that [ __ ]
you up I'm sorry that happen to you but
that doesn't reflect on my relationship
if you as an individual are with
somebody right now and every time they
leave you need to double-check where
they're going [ __ ] you are the
most insecure human being and maybe you
need to fix your relationship my
girlfriend right now she is not my boss
I do not need to ask her permission to
see what I can and can't do because you
want to know why because I have common
sense I know my girlfriend I know things
that she is okay and not okay with and
me being the respectful boyfriend that
has her trust and has not broken her
trust will know exactly what to do that
is a healthy relationship and let's
bring up another thing too if you are
with a girl or a guide assistant you
can't have any other friends with the
opposite sex
[ __ ] run away the person
your whip does not own you you are not
their property and obviously if they are
telling you who you can and cannot
associate with in your stupidest [ __ ] or
she's [ __ ] crazy or he's crazy
bitch-ass [ __ ] acting like you
didn't have a life before you got
together with somebody [ __ ] if
anything else the person that I'm with
right now she's the new fact that other
people have been there for years and if
that person is not okay with that
people who have built me up and it would
be since day one when they're the new
thing but you got to check yourself
[ __ ] so Peter I hope that answers
your questions don't worry about the
[ __ ] haters and what they say about
your relationship guess what your
relationship is between you and
everybody else that wants to say
something about your relationship tell
them to go to a kangaroo get on their
knees and suck that [ __ ] kangaroo
dick hey happy holidays it's not even a
holiday person is in pictures like hey
what are going on YouTube if you guys
want to see more videos about some crazy
life is but you know on the life of my
guru leave those comments below message
me on my Facebook fan page and make sure
that you follow me on Twitter and
Instagram because you don't want to
entertain things I'm sure like Kanye
says cuz I'm doing dope [ __ ] I'm not
really Kanye West oh because I'm not
rich like him and I don't really have
that much of a polarizing character yo
why am i stroking it no now before I got
together with her he states what I think
in my veins I see my girlfriend I say
hey baby you know what she said to me
hey babe